so we're going to start today with this
incredible
interview that took place with the now
acquitted kyle rittenhouse on the fox
news channel's tucker carlson program
this was a much promoted interview and
it confirms every single one of our
suspicions about how kyle rittenhouse
would be treated after his acquittal
which is
they're making a hero out of him or at
least they're trying to and as you watch
these clips
consider the types of issues on which
this 18 year old kid
who killed two people when he was 17
is being not only asked to weigh in but
tucker's reactions a full grown man
reacting as if this is who we should be
asking about such issues as
the fbi
prosecutorial misconduct
self-defense and on and on and on so
this is not only
the exact predictable attempt to make a
hero out of kyle rittenhouse that we
predicted but it is actually making him
to be even more than that it's making
him an authority on self-defense it's
making him
so many more things so let's just jump
right into it tucker carlson introducing
this
and
saying
this is the type of person
you want
more of in your country if you can
imagine that
during the course of our long
conversation colorado now struck us as
bright decent sincere dutiful and
hardworking exactly the kind of person
you'd want many more of in your country
he's not especially political he never
wanted to be the symbol of anything so
even just starting this
with this is just a great guy i'm tucker
and you trust me and i tell you all the
time what we need in this country and we
need more kyle written houses that's how
they set the stage and then immediately
you have kyle rittenhouse saying
this was about self-defense this trial
was about self-defense big picture which
the right loves he's their hero
it wasn't kyle ridden house on trial in
wisconsin it was the right to
self-defense on trial
and
if i was convicted
no one would be able
no one would ever be privileged to
defend their life against attackers
now what kyle rittenhouse wants you to
believe
and what others want you to believe
is that if in this particular case there
had been a conviction
and again it could have been a
conviction just on one of the counts it
could have been well
with the rosenbaum killing it wasn't
self-defense but maybe with anthony
huber it was which i my instinct was if
there was going to be any guilty verdict
that would have been written house and
it would have been rosenbaum and not
huber but that's neither here nor there
he wants you to believe any any guilty
verdict here would mean people can't
defend themselves anymore
however that's an extremely myopic view
of the facts which include his choice to
go there and his choice to go to provide
medical help supposedly but with a gun
and on and on this is not about
adjudicating the trial but it's the idea
that what does this 18 year old know
about self-defense he got himself into
an insane situation got away with
killing two people under the guise of
self-defense but now we're going to him
for advice about self-defense and what
this means it's crazy
of course at a certain point you've got
to bring up god and he believes he had
god on his side you know you just got
acquitted yeah i mean like two days ago
so that was the first thing i noticed
that you seem very calm
you don't seem like someone who's just
been through
you know had his mind blown
yeah on the inside i'm freaking out but
the best thing you do you freak out
everybody else freaks out it's like a
chain reaction yes so the best thing i
can do is stay calm
do you feel like you've been watched
over
i believe god's been on my side in the
beginning yeah there you go i mean what
what what an amazing perspective that
tucker is eliciting here right
and the entire interview was essentially
like this and if you what's very
interesting is
it really illuminates the difference
between a propaganda interview and a
real interview because now we're going
to look at an example of when written
house is allowed to get away
with
something with tucker
that he never would have been able to
get away with in court he says you know
after i did shoot joseph rosenbaum
i was going to render first aid when in
the trial
through cross-examination it was clear
that that that was not the case well he
gets shot
you decide at that point
listen miss remembering you're you want
to go turn yourself into the police
yes
um
after i shoot mr rosenbaum
um
he tried to grab my gun i was running
away there's a gunshot behind me after i
shoot him i run around the car because i
was going to go render first aid to him
even this i mean this this story is not
the story that came out in the trial
rosenbaum grabbed my gun
in order to take it from kyle
rittenhouse that's a detail that was
left unclear from the case i'm not
saying was or wasn't self-defense again
i as i said from the beginning i think
the facts lend themselves to a
reasonable doubt that this was
self-defense as kyle rittenhouse saw it
but this story he tried to grab my gun
and i still ran around the car to try to
give him first aid after the first shot
that's not really what the video appears
to show but in a propaganda interview
you're allowed to get away with it i
wasn't able to because then
there was a mob forming and
calling for my execution to get him and
kill him and of course what's in between
that that kyle rittenhouse doesn't
mention are the three further shots to
rosenbaum
after rosenbaum was already seemingly
disabled so it's not about relitigating
the case it's about understanding that
this is a propaganda interview where
he's allowed to give any version of
events even versions of events not
backed up by the exhibits presented in
the trial uh and and that conflict with
with what came out in the trial okay um
let's look at another clip here
this case has nothing to do with race um
it never had anything to do with race it
had to do with the right to self-defense
right
i'm not a racist person i support the
blm movement i support peacefully
demonstrating
and i believe there needs to be change i
believe there's a lot of prosecutorial
misconduct not just in my case but in
other cases
and it's just amazing to see
how
how much a prosecutor can take advantage
of somebody
so
once again this is another one of those
examples of
18 year old kyle rittenhouse on
prosecutorial misconduct they're making
him an authority they're making him a
hero they're making him a poster child
when just because you were accused of a
crime
doesn't mean you know anything about
supposed prosecutorial misconduct and he
knows that now oh and people are
commenting oh he supports blm okay maybe
we have no idea what that means maybe he
does i'm not denying that he does it
might just mean he supports blm insofar
as they have a right to be heard at
protests
it could mean it doesn't really matter
here but he's learning the talking
points and in this next clip you're
going to see him do the fbi stuff which
is remember among the right now you have
to criticize the fbi
and he says
i don't know if they're going to be able
to keep me safe you know how the fbi
works which this this is
classic red meat to those who know what
to listen for it to look at the facts of
what happened
do you feel the threats
i do i see some of the threats some of
the things people say it's absolutely
sickening
has do are you confident that the
government will protect you from these
threats because that's of course the
government's job
i hope so but we all know how the fbi
works
yeah
i mean
looking back
it's been
you know okay
um so he he's on but he knows the
talking points he knows it we got to be
very skeptical and critical of the fbi
that's something that grew significantly
under trump
um and that has become sort of a
standard calling card now of right-wing
media so he's he's got that one he
learned that one for sure the topic of
joe biden came up and um kyle
rittenhouse even given the opportunity
to send a message directly to president
joe biden besides like my case what did
you make of the president united states
calling you a white supremacist
mr president if i could say one thing to
you i would urge you to go back and
watch the trial
and understand the facts before you make
a statement
that's not a small thing to be called
that
no it's
it's actual malice defaming my character
for him to say something like that
defaming defamation we're gonna come
back to that because that actually comes
up again now in the midst of this
you might remember that all sorts of
shady characters got wrapped up with
kyle rittenhouse early on one of them is
lynn wood this
sort of trump-affiliated wacky attorney
who's made all sorts of insane claims
about
uh kovid as well as about the 2020
elections and this is this is sort of a
departure from what we've been talking
about
um
he uh kyle rittenhouse talks about how
he believes he was taken advantage of by
some of these lawyers who were raising
money for themselves and he was kept in
jail and it's actually this is this is
just a crazy aspect to this
how long were you there i was in jail
for 87 days and
this goes as follows in with lynn wood
who
lynnwood
was raising money on my behalf and he
held me in jail for 87 days disrespected
my wishes put me on media interviews
which i should never have done when she
said oh you're going to go talk to the
washington post which was not a good
idea along with john pierce they said i
was safer in jail instead of at home
with my family and then after i'm built
your lawyer said that my lawyer said
that john pearson lynn wood
87 days is a long time to be in jail
it was it was very long i lost a lot of
weight in there i i since then gained it
back
i know the feeling yeah
so this is crazy this is a propaganda
interview but it also shows you that
um
these sort of predatory
figures like lynn wood they're
everywhere and there's no opportunity
that they won't take advantage of uh and
here rittenhouse talks about
how he was treated in jail now there's
two there's two sides to this part let's
listen split
um
but i didn't have running water
seriously i had a phone also but i did
not have running water so i didn't
shower until november 20th
from october 31st to november 20th i did
not take a shower that's disgusting i it
very um i smelled terrible i felt sick i
lost a weight my health was degrading
yeah so what's interesting about this
one is
this has happened in the context of the
january six riots as well
where
you know we
by we i mean we on the left
have been sounding the alarm about jail
and prison conditions pre-trial
detention etc for more than a decade on
this program
and the right
has not cared about it until
it affects them
and so now you've heard everybody from
marjory taylor green to who knows who on
the right complain about the alleged
conditions conditions in which the
alleged january 6th trump rioters have
been held and now
jail conditions all of a sudden are a
big deal to them and similarly now all
of a sudden with the written house stuff
that issue is now they care about that
issue now it's actually an important
issue
but it's again
the brazen nature
by which they only care about it when it
affects them
there have been questions is kyle
rittenhouse going to sue media outlets
for things they said about him various
legal opinions about whether that would
go anywhere but kyle rittenhouse sort of
using coded language to say yeah we may
do that um and they would like to see
you
you know help make this better by
holding some of these liars to account
do you plan to do that i have really
good lawyers who are taking care of that
right now um
so
i'm hoping one day there will be some
there would be accountability for their
actions that they did okay so you're
you're intent on not you're not gonna
let that go
uh like i said
so
suggesting there that they there may
well be defamation suits coming and
where those will go we have absolutely
no idea but it's looking like this is
going to be a very litigious year or two
for kyle rittenhouse and then lastly uh
kyle rittenhouse the the lionization and
the heroism continues with kyle
talking about what kind of a career he
wants to pursue what do you think your
life's going to be like after this
i'm hoping i can live a quiet
stress-free life
and not and be free of any intimidation
or harassment and just go on with my
life as a normal 18 year old kid
attending college
so you're gonna go to college i am in
college i'm a student at arizona state
university now
in the trial it
it seems like that was not true unless
something has changed but that's really
neither here nor there
well i mean are you going to go to
campus and
i i think i am i want to um it's a lot
of things we have to look into so i
don't know for sure yet
but i i do intend on going in campus and
pursuing a career in nursing
i may change it i've been looking into
law i may want to become a lawyer i
haven't completely decided yet
but i've been looking i want to be a
nurse so i've been doing the
prerequisites for how nice right so
exactly as predicted this is the new
hero this is the new hero and of course
you can judge for yourselves based on
your values uh and how you see the world
whether you think that he's worthy of
being designated this hero but weighing
in on everything from prosecutorial
misconduct to the trustworthiness of the
fbi on the basis of the fact that he
killed two people and was acquitted for
it um exactly as we predicted on
december 14th we will be doing our next
david pakman show viewer town hall it
will be on the pacman live youtube
channel make sure you're subscribed to
that channel at youtube.compacmanlive
we're going to take a quick break and be
back right after this
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't be the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get twenty percent off when you go to
allform.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video